u.s president biden's first stop in
south korea
a computer chip plant by samsung that
could serve as a model for a
multi-billion dollar facility being
built in the u.s
that underscores the importance of the
semiconductor industry
computer chips power modern technology
from vehicles to artificial intelligence
but a global chip shortage since the
pandemic has affected the availability
of many of these
products three quarters of global chip
production comes from asia
the biden administration is now looking
to shift some of that to the us
how we'll do that in my view is by
working with close partners who do share
our values like the republic of korea to
secure more of what we need from our
allies and partners and bolster our
supply chain resilience
the move is also partly driven by
china's drive for self-sufficiency in
chip production with the government
pouring billions of dollars into the
industry for the us to maintain its
technological advantage it has to invest
in computer chips
for south korea a focal point of
president biden's visit is an
opportunity to strengthen existing ties
into a more comprehensive partnership
i hope that today's visit will serve as
an opportunity for the rok us
relationship to be reborn as an economic
security alliance based on advanced
technology and supply chain cooperation
president biden's visit comes a week
after he hosted southeast asian leaders
at a summit in the us
analysts say these events underscore how
the indo-pacific region remains a top
priority for the biden administration
on saturday the two presidents will hold
a summit where they're expected to
discuss regional security including the
denuclearization of the korean peninsula
florence louis al jazeera seoul